io non dico al popolo il componente
principale della pena beh ciao ragazzi
bentornati un nuovo video qui sul mio
canale perché non conoscesse questa
rubrica ogni tot sui miei social compare
un messaggio di aiuto vi chiedo di
mandarmi dei dm personali su facebook
per parlare di un tema in generale il
tema di questa puntata un pochino a tema
halloween è la sfiga partiamo subito per
questa puntata ha deciso di invitare
all'interno dei miei grandi studios di
casa mia che in questo momento sono un
forno crematorio visto che è notte una
persona che non posso assolutamente
mettere davanti al termosifone perché
nessuno mette franche in un angolo e
ciao
siamo pronti quindi a questo punto per
girare il video io non so come funziona
guglielmo allora ti farò ascoltare dei
messaggi
torneremo di sfigato è molto semplice ok
ma dobbiamo dargli dei consigli
ma diciamo che già la nostra amicizia di
base proprio capitale
scusate se lati un pochino basso conio
computer per casta botta non mi funziona
il telefono appena nata che produrrà da
anni e alla fine mi hanno detto che è
gay
decide di metterci le ventilate tra
sopra e non trova dato sopra la
situazione si fidanza in tempo record
con un'altra ragazza a lui usare la
nostra cosa passeggera ma sbaglio perché
vanno addirittura a convivere finita
interessarmi ad un altro ancora anche
lui si fidanza mentre cerco di
dichiararmi anche loro contro ancora
adesso sono felicemente fidanzati in più
una settimana fa mi si rompe il
cellulare il pc e adesso non mi va più
lightroom nell'auto pc che mi è rimasto
di cosa non gli ha dato nomi infine alla
lightning a light rombo 6 sfigata in
trovare ragazza l'ha pizzicata è stato
quando una sera ubriaca tradita al bar o
fermato una macchina per chiedere un
passaggio per vallo
la mia casa è sopra la macchina c'era
mia madre
ciao ma ringrazio dio che certo di buon
maniaco no però questa è fortuna si è
infatti fu però è sfortuna se appena
entra in macchina tua madre di limone
abbiamo visto che quando incontri un
ragazzo carino amici a frequentare messi
possa essere quello giusto e poi scopri
che soffre di personalità dissociate ma
questo mi ha solo nominato la giornata
sentire questo poi non ha spiegato
niente marilena cioè può essere pure il
ragazzo stesso con un'altra personalità
che si manda il messaggio contro se
stessa in realtà potrebbe pure essere
che marilena non voleva sa farsi piacere
lì però con qualcosa di più massimo ma
diciamo mango assieme lo usi come pesaro
mango city che nel senso che le piattole
mi son durate quattro mesi ma poi sulla
l'onorevole un bacio
ho preso la mollo cleo riconosciuta al
bar e non è sola volta ho parlato perché
la macchina
il giorno dopo prendere a cambiare pelle
totino di scott e cantello la ruota ha
spiegato che non è che cosa mi piace che
cosa dice io ho la mononucleosi ma con
rea però a volte buco la roma ma
dall'altro ha avuto la colonna con un
bacio a ecco luca si pensi che quando al
lavoro incontri finalmente una ragazza
carina invadenti sembra anche
disponibile leggeri di uscire per andare
a prendere una birra andrei al primo
giorno dopo nemmeno essere di pace di
chi deve andare a convivere
questo scrive nell'incontro di norma ma
si sa c'è come durante la primavera gli
ha detto andiamo andiamo a compiti
comunque l'avrà pure detto un po
morsicata come tema che come ora dopo
proprio i pezzi dei miti danzati di
tempo solitamente nel reparto del
freezer raccontarti mille dei topi che
mi sono successi di sfida per accorrere
serino settimane si sa inserire
gratuitamente facendo la baby sitter ma
da cambiare il pannolino del bambino la
foto la racca il bambino magicamente
decide di giocarsi volere perché pagata
per dovuto con il pannolino che becca
sporco ha macchiato il bianco è che
bianchi paolo ii scuola retto scusa
questo spirito e ora c'è il figlio che
non è la prima volta che l'ha fatto
compra divani ne rimane serie b si lo so
ma li genitori se lo sanno che il figlio
morente che gli ospiti con mango speedy
gonzales in giro per casa o magari da
grande diventerà un writer volta quando
calzi di corsa alla mattina
tanto perché io sono sempre in ritardo
prendi velocemente il dentifricio lo
applichi sullo spiazzo nino da 20 e ti
metti a lavare i denti e soltanto dopo
un minuto di spazzolata molto profondo
ti accorgi che invece di aver preso il
20 ficio hai preso la pipì clima di
pullman
la mia domanda è ma la b ma non ve ne
state mentali sì ma in fa un minuto di
spazzolato vuol dire che ti piace
vuol dire che non sei denti fattispecie
perfezione il colletto di un bambino
perché mai detto ai denti
una volta mi hanno regalato questo
titolo ante e molto costoso stick ok
molto costose me l'hanno fatto capire
pure i miei amici che mi faceva ridere
che mai avevano speso un sacco di soldi
per un detto grande steve e io ero
felice perché ho sempre usato i
deodoranti quelli in proprio quelli che
egli uso tutte le visioni miei preferiti
per concluso sto del grande steve una
serata un sabato che detto perché lo
volevo portare la speciale dove lo metto
e niente e scoprono non mi sembrava
fortissimo poi nei prossimi giorni ho
visto che era molto debole di profumo
proprio lo continuamente poi lo vado ad
annusare così e puzza di sudore
no è logico massa cose hanno speso un
sacco di soldi che comunque viene un
amico mia casa lo apre e ci toglie la
pellicola io per settimane sta
commettendo integrante ci aveva ancora
la pellicola trasparente
quindi io praticamente passavo
e stato un giorno di tanti anni fa il
mio ragazzo venuto a casa mia e così di
punto in bianco mi ha lasciato ed è
andato via dopo un po mi sono
addormentata sei sveglio cercato il
cellulare sul comodino per vedere se
sono sotto un sogno ho pensato e nel
prenderlo è scivolato e ha battuto sullo
spigolo di un terzo se hai spezzato e
mille vecchi allora per recuperare se
volare o stato un bicchiere d'acqua e
dichiara l'acqua the rovesciata sul
cellulare che quindi arango lo sa bene
tutto un giorno festivo arrivati è vero
che questo è il terribile che si
succedono poi vi chiedo ancora sullo
spigolo cioè come ho fatto per prendere
il cellulare vuol dire che cellulare sta
per terra risollevato forse ce l'aveva
in mano e che faccio più bella forse
stava dormendo colpisce io quello non lo
voglio più vedere
mango come nome whatsapp usavo luccio
letta
dovevo inviarmi dei messaggi con il mio
ginecologo per delle analisi
e allora detto facciamo la persona che
amo il mio nome niente mando messaggi
lui mi risponde a tutto bene
la sea miste cosa è sicuro di me con
scherno ma scusa perché possono
arrivarvi notifiche di te con ricetta
cioè io al ginecologo scritto come
perché sa che faccine usi quando scriver
ginecologo e vero dice di quelle che io
chiamo chiamati con cioè beh ci sono
delle delle emoticon che ti servono un
pochino sì tipo quella lì con con
il sorrisino quella con lucchetti dei
fuori sede reggiana 15 o la candida e
mette la melanzana no o la candida e
metti tipo che ne so la scimmietta che
si chiama si copre gli altri ma anche
imbarazzata ansa messina 2 si aspettava
nelle relazioni ogni tanto che quando mi
frequento
non so perché ma riescono a frequentarmi
o con ragazzi si rivelano essere poi
delle psicopatiche il dire e quindi
ovviamente forse cose non si può più
fare questo presentazione oppure sono
fidanzato oppure dovranno gli extra
provviso grafica molto tranquilla di
caprone fisica e psicologica di sicuro
guarda mango ti suggerisco inizia a
provare i ragazzi sanno deluderti molto
di peggio
per quanto riguarda la sfiga la sfiga
essere follemente innamorata di una
ragazza che viene continuamente trattata
malissimo da tutti i ragazzi che
incontra
eppure non poter rendere felice questa
feccia in alcun modo perchè lei è la si
è lanciato dal balcone dava con l'iphone
fatto comando prima un messaggino che
ammazza e niente ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video io vi
ringrazio perché ogni volta mi mi
scrivete in tanti ed è bello poterli
ascoltare ringrazio anche frank per
essere venuto qui ha fatto ridere
moltissimo grazie
e niente so che pure diviene una cosa sì
tutti quanti ci stavano no abbiamo
parlato di sfiga e quindi quello che
possiamo fare noi e grattarci mango
quale trovare di mango manchi manchi per
togliervi da tutte le sfighe che vi sono
accadute quindi lo stiamo facendo in
questo ma non a vicenda forse noi
rimangono veramente marco mango
[Risate]